(audience cheering and applauding)
(upbeat music)
♪ Here's the thing, we
started out friends ♪
♪ It was cool, but it was all pretend ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ You're dedicated, you took the time ♪
♪ Wasn't long 'til I called you mine ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ How come I never hear you say ♪
♪ I just want to be with you ♪
♪ I guess you never felt that way ♪
♪ But since you been gone ♪
♪ I can breathe for the first time ♪
♪ I'm so moving on ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Thanks to you ♪
♪ Now I get what I want, yeah ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ You had your chance, you blew it ♪
♪ Out of sight, out of mind ♪
♪ Shut your mouth, I just can't take it ♪
♪ Again, and again, and again, and again ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
- Come on sing it with us.
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ I can breathe for the first time ♪
♪ I'm so moving on ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Thanks to you ♪
♪ Now I get ♪
♪ You should know ♪
♪ I always get ♪
♪ I get what I want ♪
♪ Since you been gone ♪
♪ Yeah, baby since you been gone ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Give it up.
All right, everybody.
Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Give it up for my band, Y'all.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Give it up for Lorna Courtney
of the Broadway musical "And Juliet".
The musical feature songs
written by Max Martin
including "Since U Been Gone".
Lorna is excellent.
I love singing with you.
Y'all got to check that out.
So, Lorna, how's the show going?
- The show is going amazing, Kelly.
Thank you so much for asking.
- Absolutely.
- This is a really exciting time
because it is Tony Awards season.
Woo woo!
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- So come on out.
It's a party every
single night on Broadway.
Come to New York and see us.
Woohoo, we love you.
- And there's so many hits.
That show is like, I
don't think people realize
how much Max Martin has done.
Like it's an incredible amount of hits
that you're gonna know
when you go see the show.
Thank you so much, Lorna.
I enjoyed singing with you.
Thanks so much for coming.
- I loved singing with you too, Kelly.